Buddy!
Hello, hello!
Feels sorta like deja vu.
Look at this tiny little guy right here.
Silence, you are tiny.
What do you mean?
Look at you, you saw.
Look at this little baby.
You know what?
No, you should be tiny.
What do you mean shrunk for me?
That's your real size.
What do you mean?
Oh, you sound quiet.
Okay, let me raise you a little bit higher.
Is this better guys?
Sorry, we're using in-game mic, so like...
Yeah, so I have to like lower the game volume.
Wait, you scared?
What do you mean?
No, because the game volume will be louder than you.
Yeah, to be really honest, I don't really hear your voice too.
Yeah, you have to lower the in-game volume so you can hear me.
I have you all the way up on voice though.
Is this better guys?
Let me know if this is better.
I'm gonna... I can turn...
Oh, I can lower the music volume.
That's awesome.
Yeah, yeah, we can lower like all the game stuff and then... Oh, nice.
That's nice for me.
That's way better for me.
Awesome.
Alright, how's the... How's Yu-san's volume now?
Is doing it... Does it...
A bit louder.
Okay, eat your mic.
Eat your mic.
Yeah, yeah, I think I'm just gonna increase my mic game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do you mean?
What will be?
Do I need to increase mine?
Ah ah ah ah ah ah.
How about now?
A bit louder?
A bit more?
Okay, I'll... I'll... I'll increase...
Oh God, I'm gonna like... When you start screaming, that's when I'm scared.
I'm just gonna try my best not to scream.
In a horror game?
I don't want to do any dramatic scream.
Yeah, yeah, because you're known to not scream.
Yeah, then, you know...
I want to focus on controlling my sanity today.
Oh...
Entertaining dramatic scream.
You know what I mean?
All right, how's you sound?
Is you sound better now?
Are they better?
Doki's loud.
Okay, it's you loud.
I'm not loud.
Okay.
Well, I'm always loud.
What do you mean?
I'm always loud.
If I'm quiet, there's something wrong.
All right, for those who don't know who Yusan is, they are a very talented singer.
And...
Whoa, why do I hear myself?
Why do I hear myself?
Do I have my stream playing?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I have my own stream playing.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, okay.
Oh, yeah, I think it's here.
Yeah, yeah, I had my own stream playing.
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay.
All right.
Are you a professional streamer?
What do you mean?
I just started streaming a week ago.
The stream is over.
I'm like already being...
I just started streaming a week ago.
Okay, anyway, for those who don't know who Yusan is, they are very, very talented singers.
They are very, very talented singers.
And they released a lot of covers.
You know, I heard that you got noticed by a very famous singer in Japan.
What's her name?
Ado?
Yeah, Yusan got noticed by Ado!
There was that saying, that one piece song.
That's the only thing I know!
Oh, my god.
I was about to do the self-promote, But you are like doing this for me.
I'm very good at business.
Oh my god.
Well anyway guys...
My cover in bio.
Okay your turn.
Your turn.
Promote me.
It's your turn.
I promoted you.
You have to promote me on my own channel.
Nothing Gremlin?
Dragon?
That's me.
What talents do I have?
What am I good at?
You're a professional gamer.
Oh my god.
Really?
Me?
Please.
Let's play a game.
No, no, no.
Go on.
Keep talking more about me.
She has awesome laugh.
Yeah, yeah.
Go on.
She's really good at drawing.
Oh my god.
Really?
She's really trololate.
To speaking with those non-native English speakers like me.
Oh thank you.
And she's a really good listener.
Yeah I am.
And Mr. Man is awesome.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
You didn't have to say all of this.
You did not have to.
Oh my god.
That's so nice of you.
You saw.
Thank you.
Okay release me.
Anyway.
Let's start the game.
So I've never played this game before.
I don't think Yusan you've played this game before, right?
Where are we?
Oh shit.
Yusan can't hear me.
What the fuck?
I just realized.
Yusan can't even hear me.
Where?
Yusan's talking to themselves right now.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Oh wait.
Where are they?
Okay let me.
Yusan!
Oh my god.
Yusan?
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
You're way much scarier than I am.
Oh yeah.
I look like a homeless person.
Wait I can hear myself from your side of the mic.
Oh my god.
I think you have your set on like.
On like stereo or something.
Okay hold on a moment.
I'm just gonna fix that real quick.
Okay.
You should be fine.
What about now?
Okay let me see.
Yeah yeah we're good.
Alright.
Okay so we gotta escape the back rooms.
Oh I think we have to go this way.
There's an arrow this way.
I like how you were like talking to yourself because of the.
I could see you talking to yourself.
I mean you know.
When you're scared.
You're just gonna.
You know try your best to you know.
How do I say that?
Bring your attention to something else.
So you don't have to you know.
Yeah so just.
It's not like you're alone.
This guy fucking talk.
Oh my god.
What?
Escape.
Okay this is not the right way.
I mean it's not that scary so far.
Like everything seems okay.
Escape.
As long as we're together.
Nothing bad can happen to us right?
Oh wait.
I am running out of my stamina.
Yeah that's why we gotta.
Okay that's why we have to like make sure we don't.
Cause I feel like there's gonna be a monster here soon.
I don't know.
No no.
Oh there it is there it is there it is.
Okay.
Use the ladder.
That's so easy what the fuck?
This is a horror game?
No don't jinx it.
This is so easy what do you mean Yusan?
Look there's water.
Are you wounded?
Cure yourself.
We're drinking water.
Oh my god there's walkie talkie.
Yeah yeah hello.
Yeah yeah yeah.
We can talk to each other if we split up.
Hello?
Okay okay we're fine.
Okay.
Get over here.
Cure yourself.
As long as we don't split up anxiety.
Wait what does this do?
You supposed to calm me down.
Leave one for me I need one to kill.
See I saved you one I'm a good person.
Thank you.
Okay you first.
You're welcome.
One four four seven.
One one wait where did.
Oh fuck.
Fuck you.
I can't.
I need a new gun.
Fuck off.
Oh my god.
Fuck you.
There's a dive button?
Wait I can whistle.
Wait you can whistle.
Whistle?
G G.
How do you whistle that?
G?
Wait.
Can I whistle while I'm using walkie talkie?
Oh my.
Oh my god that shit's scary.
Woo.
Scuff.
I feel like we have to know this.
Okay chat.
Remember these numbers for me.
Two three one four.
Or seven one eight nine.
This is your job chat.
You have one job.
Remember this.
Get over here.
Yusa get over here.
Okay.
How do we.
I guess we go.
One.
Oh that's what the number's for.
Why are the numbers again?
Wait what are the numbers?
I already forgot the number.
Um.
I'm gonna check real quick again.
No no no no.
That's what chat's for.
Seven.
Seven?
Seven one one three eight.
Seven one one three.
Okay that's not right.
Okay.
Four.
Four seven one one three eight.
Two nine.
Seven one one.
So some numbers are missing.
What?
Some numbers are missing there.
There's numbers missing?
I'm so confused.
Me too.
Uhhhh.
I'm so.
No.
Why is there a puzzle?
Why is there?
I have no idea.
Why did they make a puzzle?
Anyway.
Look around.
Wait I see so many people pressing.
Telling me to press these numbers.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Chat is backseating you.
Wait but it's not working.
What do they mean?
Seven.
Four.
Oh no I already lost.
Wait are you cheating right now?
No I'm not cheating.
No no no.
This is a stream.
What do you mean wow?
What do you mean?
What awesome professional gamer behavior.
You're okay.
Gamers always ask chat for help.
The big.
I am very mature and I am willing to ask for help.
I am willing to ask for help.
That's when you know I am a gamer.
Okay.
So I'm going to press the nine.
One.
I am so disappointed on this.
Okay.
What do the numbers mean?
Don't do that.
Okay then you solve this.
You're so smart.
Yeah?
Do it.
Solve it.
So I say that some numbers are missing here.
Like which one?
So five.
So far I know five is missing.
Why do you know five?
Oh okay.
There's no five.
There's no six.
Yeah.
Zero?
Do we have zero in the...
No it's only one.
Why would there be a floor zero on an elevator?
You son.
Where the fuck is floor zero?
What is...
Zero doesn't exist.
You know yeah I'm just thinking something more logical.
How is zero as an elevator number logical?
Floor B!
Come on you know.
This is something.
This is the teamwork.
Yeah.
We're gonna help each other to solve it.
My teamwork is getting chat to help.
Come on yeah.
Let's focus.
So five, six.
Okay zero.
No zero.
Okay no zero.
There's no five.
There's no six.
Okay I'll type that in.
Wait okay.
Five, six, three.
Three.
What's the last one?
Seven?
No there was a seven wasn't there?
It's not this.
Eight.
Oh no there's eight.
Seven there is yeah.
It's seven one nine eight.
Why is it seven one one?
Why is it seven one nine eight?
Seven one nine eight.
It was not seven one nine eight.
Who said that bad in this person?
This is the reason why you shouldn't trust in chat.
And it's your own mistake.
Okay?
Yeah.
Wait look at that.
There is B.
Wait there is B.
Yeah but I can't press B.
Look at that.
There is zero.
Zero.
B is a letter.
Zero is a number.
Basement is basement.
But who is the one that's roasting me for pointing out the number zero?
It's basement one two three four five.
Because no one puts basement as a zero.
Everyone puts basement as basement.
I'm not talking about that.
It's basement one two three four five six seven eight.
Or G ground level.
One two three four five six seven eight.
I'm not talking like that.
Come on.
This is teamwork.
Listen.
Okay?
This is teamwork.
I'm educating you on elevators.
I'm trying to educate you.
I'm trying to educate you on elevators.
Chad help.
Look it's basement lobby.
One two three four five six seven eight.
Wait why is it 1987?
Where did you get 1987 from?
I'm pointing out the thing to solve the puzzle.
But she decided to roast me.
What the hell?
Okay.
Why is it 1987?
Explain.
1987?
On the roll call?
Okay.
1987.
Nineteen...
Eighty-seven.
Oh my god we did it!
I told you!
I'm not happy with it.
We did it guys!
We're so smart.
We're so fucking smart.
This is so questionable.
I am not.
Oh my god.
This is the fight of 87.
We will never know why.
We will never know why that was the correct answer.
But it worked.
It worked.
That's all that matters.
I don't like this.
It's getting darker now.
We go this way.
Okay.
Did you hear that?
As long as we're together nothing bad can happen.
Wait what's this?
Water.
Almond water.
It can save you so make sure you watch your stamina.
It can save you.
What's this?
Wait.
That's a new spot.
It resembles a dog due to the fact that no one has managed to photo.
Oh.
Amber.
It also is known and is terminated by direct eye contact.
I was roasting you.
Wait.
It's scared.
It doesn't like noise.
It says it doesn't like noise.
No I didn't hear that noise.
There's no noise.
Let's move.
I'm following you.
Wait does it like whistles?
Stop it.
Good boy.
Where is he?
Oh.
No.
What is that?
It's a locker.
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
So whenever I found an enemy.
Whenever I encountered an enemy.
We can just be here.
Oh my god.
Your head is...
Wait why is it right outside?
Get out.
I heard something.
What do you hear?
Hello?
I heard.
I heard that I see.
There's only one locker.
Come over here.
Wait.
Please.
Get out.
What a dialogue.
I don't like this collab.
What do you mean?
Are you having fun?
I'm having so much fun.
Wait.
We found a room.
No.
It's just more rooms.
It's just more back rooms.
Oh my god.
Where are we?
Wait.
What is that?
It's a shadow.
Oh it's a horse.
It's a horse.
How do I?
Oh yeah.
Easy.
Then what do we do with the horse?
I have no idea.
Wait.
Oh it's a door.
It's a door.
Open the door.
Wait what?
It's looking to R.
It seems that the clock...
Oh wait we need to find...
Wait there's a... It's a clock.
There is a clock.
Yeah.
We need to find clock hands.
Okay.
Okay so there's a clock inside so we need to find a clock hand.
Okay so...
Are we gonna get inside this door?
R?
What is wrong?
Alright we need to find...
We need to find clock hands.
Yeah.
So we're gonna get in here right?
No I already got in here and it's like...
We're missing items.
Oh okay.
Yeah we're missing a clock hands.
Okay.
Guys don't do that.
No.
Don't do that.
Hello?
We're not gonna take any risk.
You know?
Hello?
I need to mention you that you're playing with a fucking beginner.
Wait I have never played this game before.
You've watched videos of this.
I haven't.
Nothing here.
Dead end.
Okay.
Where do we go?
I'm already lost.
Did we come here before?
Me too.
Wait did we come here?
I don't know where we are.
I don't know too.
I have no sense of direction.
Come on you're good at... Oh my god.
No no.
What everyone knows about me is that I don't know where I am.
This is a dead end.
Have we been here?
She's...
They're dead!
Ah!
Okay.
Well I don't think we're...
I don't...
I don't think we're getting out of here.
How am I supposed to drink my almond milk?
I can't even...
I...
How am I supposed to drink my almond milk?
Vintori!
Didn't think
I...
I can't even open my inventory.
How do I move?!
Okay...
Smells like...
Who's that?
Is that you?
Oh my god!
That's Yusa!
Oh, we're so fucked.
We're so fucked.
Yusa, where are you going?
Yusa, where did you go?
Where did Yusa's shadow go?
I'm so scared!
Oh my god, where do I...
Leave me alone!
Yusa!
Look for the flashlight!
If you can hear me right now!
Yusa!
Look for the flashlight!
And lead me to the flashlight!
Oh god.
I'm so fucked.
You know what, what if I just die?
You know what?
Come over here.
What if I don't want to do this alone anymore?
What if I just die?
Yusa, did you find the flashlight?
Where is it?
Where's your shadow?
Where's the shadow?
Where's Yusa's shadow?
There's the shadow.
It's not me!
Okay, here.
You see that?
You see this box?
Yeah.
Yeah, open that.
No, not the locker!
No, don't get... Get out of the locker!
Be brave!
No!
You said open it!
You sacrificed your face!
Where are you going?
Where are you?
Here, here, here, here, here, here, here, here.
Where is here?
Yeah?
What's the password?
Oh, Yusa.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Oh, there's your shadow.
Okay.
Oh, I found more meds.
And almond water.
Okay.
But like, what's the code?
How do I...
What's the code?
Okay.
I can't... I can't switch...
How do...
Wait.
How do I move?
How do I move that?
Okay.
Nineteen...
Eighty-seven...
Who opened the door?
Please.
Please!
Oh, it's a drag!
Okay, I figured it out.
It's not 1987.
It was not a swipe.
It was a drag.
I figured it out.
It's not 1987!
Oh my God.
It was not the bite of 87, guys.
We figured it out.
It was not the bite of 87.
Oh my God.
Wait.
We'll close the...
Oh, boy.
Fuck you.
We'll never figure this out.
Okay, but if we close the door...
Maybe, like, nothing will hurt me.
Okay.
The drag of 87.
I was panicking!
Okay.
We'll never figure out why this is...
Why...
How to get the right answer.
Oh my God.
Why would it be 1983?
What happened in 1983?
I still don't know how we got 1987 from the last quarter.
What if I...
I still don't know how we got that.
I still...
Oh, wait.
Maybe it is 1987.
And I just need to...
Wait.
Maybe it is.
I just need...
No, it's not.
It's not.
Oh my God.
It's another bite.
Wait.
Yusa, where did you go?
I don't know.
Wait.
Time nobody give me.
We'll never figure it out.
Yusa, where are you?
Yusa!
Where they go?
Where they...
Yusa, please?
Why was I the one that died first?
Why couldn't it be me?
Oh my God.
Push the door then...
Can you break the lock?
Okay, if I could break the lock I would have just thrown the fucking box down right now.
We need lockpick master here.
Who's that?
Hello?
Oh, it's the stick figure guy.
It's him again.
Okay, someone call MatPat.
Oh my god.
Okay, but what if I just die?
Look, we're still in the beginning.
It wouldn't matter if I just perished.
Because we're still in the beginning of the level.
Like, does it really matter?
Does it really matter?
Maybe he'll open it.
Okay.
Alright, you know what?
I'm gonna... you know what?
I'm gonna do it.
It wouldn't fucking matter.
It wouldn't... it wouldn't matter.
How does it matter?
You can revive... how?
Where can I revive them?
Oh my god.
Where do I revive them?
I have just Almond Water.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
My Almond Water.
I'm so fucking scared.
I'm so scared.
Yu-san, do you hear me?
You need to find the Door of Light.
Follow the light, Yu-san.
Follow the light.
So you can come back.
I'll wait here in the locker.
What do you mean no?
Just find the light and I'll wait here.
Find the light and come back here.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Yu-san, find the light.
I can stay in the...
I don't think I can stay in the locker.
Yu-san?
So many fucking lockers, man.
Why is there... maybe this can be broken with something?
A fucking screwdriver?
No, screwdrivers can't...
Okay, maybe this is a bad idea to play with two people.
I just realized.
Maybe that's a fucking bad...
Who's that?
Oh my god.
What the fuck was that?
You can't hear Yu-san?
Because they're dead!
You can't hear them because the dead can't talk!
That's what it means.
You're not supposed to ghost people.
There's no ghosting allowed.
Alright.
Why can't I just throw the fucking...
The vase on the ground?
It's a fucking vase!
I need to finish reading this.
Oh, I need a hammer.
Where the fuck is the hammer?
Why can't I just throw the fucking vase?
It's made of glass!
This is so fucking dumb.
Oh hey, there's a head.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Yu-san, find the light!
Find the light!
Please!
Come!
I swear to god, if you do not find the light right now, I will let this monster here kill me.
I don't care about my fucking almond water.
I don't care.
Okay, where the fuck is the monster?
Come over here.
I'm gonna...
Where the fuck is the...
Come over here.
I don't care anymore.
Yu-san would not find the light.
Something will come over and fucking rip me apart.
Oh hey, there's more almond water that I can't use.
I can't even carry it!
I have too much almond water!
Something will fucking kill me.
There we go.
That's fucking right!
That's right!
You did this, Yu-san!
Where is he?
Where's the stick figure guy?
Wait, what?
Hello?
Yeah, that's right!
Come on, kill me!
Hello?
Where is it?
What the fuck?
Get over here.
They're stuck in the wall!
What the fuck?
Oh my God, it can't even do the simple job!
Oh my God, it was stuck in the wall.
Get over here.
OK.
It's less scary when it's just smacking me in the face.
It's a lot less scary.
Follow the...
We both need a fire!
Are you kidding me?
It's like five?
Okay.
Well, I gotta find the door now.
He's on!
You had five minutes to find the door!
All right.
I guess I'll find the door.
All right, where the fuck is the door?
Find the luminous door and revive.
You mean you had five minutes to find the fucking door and you didn't find the fucking door?
Okay, well we found the fucking...
There's a teddy bear.
Okay, there's a radioactive door.
Holy shit.
What are all these items?
This is such a bad...
idea to play as a duo.
We should have been a full squad.
I can't believe it and it was my idea to play this game too.
Okay.
Can't you hear Yuson?
I don't think Yuson's close to me.
I think Yuson's trying to find the door as well.
Wait, I heard it.
It was shimmering.
You heard that?
I heard like a shimmering sound.
Where is it?
God, do the hard mode?
This is normal mode and we're fucking struggling!
I might even do easy mode after this!
At this rate.
Wait, I found it!
Wait.
Wait, oh!
Oh!
Wait, this is it!
Yuson!
Get over here!
This has to be it!
Wait, what?
This is it!
Okay.
Maybe... I'm gonna wait a minute.
I'm gonna wait a minute.
Yuson has to show up.
Yuson!
Wait, that's Yuson?
Wait, what would that be, Yuson?
That's me?
That's a... This is the door!
This has to be the door!
Where is Yuson?
It's just me?
I have nine lives!
Yuson, you have no excuse!
I have nine...
I have nine lives!
Oh my god!
We're restarting!
You suck!
I'm not doing this!
Fuck you!
Like this, I'm doing it on easy!
I'm doing it on easy!
Lumau!
Fuck you!
Donkey!
What did I do?
Oh my god...
Lumau.
What the fuck do you mean?
You had her!
Why did you find the door?
I... I... I died.
And I can't do anything if I died.
You know?
You can!
You can find the door!
You find...
Yeah, I didn't know that.
Yeah, I didn't know that I have to find the door.
Sorry about that.
You had to find the door!
You know what?
Now we know.
Now we know how to do that.
What about we just gonna figure it out?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now we're better.
We're better people now.
Look at that.
Back here we go again.
I'm gonna get... I'm gonna get a ball.
Come on.
You know?
Alright.
Okay, now we know what to do.
Now we know.
Yeah.
We can... we can rush this.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna grab the almond water.
Give it to me!
You can have this.
You can have the other one.
Where is that?
The spray can?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so I don't remember.
I don't remember where to go.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna follow you.
I'm gonna follow you.
No, no, no, no.
Let's not get into somewhere dark.
You know, maybe we can just follow the...
When you find a fl... Apparently there was a flashlight that we missed.
Yeah.
Oh, we can get a flashlight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a flashlight.
Wait, you saw it?
Hello?
Yeah.
Oh, there you are.
There you are.
Okay.
Okay, there's apparently like a flash... Oh, that's a mirror.
Holy shit.
That's...
Oh my god.
Okay, there's like... Wait, there's a TV.
Cannot turn on at this moment.
Did you hear that?
No.
Cannot turn on this...
I'm gonna pretend I didn't.
And we... Don't acknowledge it.
It didn't happen.
Okay.
There's like apparently a flashlight somewhere.
Oh, they're in the drawers.
Oh.
Oh, the drawer.
Is there a flashlight?
Wait.
No, that's anxiety.
You can have that.
I'll get it.
Yeah.
Okay.
We have to find...
We have to... Wait, there's a door here.
Oh, it's just two lockers.
It's just lockers.
Oh, guys.
I'll just say lockers.
Oh,
what?
What?
Oh, there's not for hiding.
Oh.
I can't even get on inside.
What the fuck?
There's...
There's shells.
I can't even get out in here.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Let's go.
Right.
Okay.
I heard a head step.
No, no.
Okay.
Okay, I think my favorite part was the fucking scream in the distance.
You saw find the door.
Find the door you saw.
Find the door.
I'll wait here.
You have nine lives.
I swear you'll be able to find the door.
It's so easy.
How did I sacrifice them?
They're the ones that died.
I saw red light.
Okay.
There they are.
They found the door.
I saw red light.
Okay.
You saw found the door.
You saw it.
Oh wait, they don't have a radio.
I'm alive.
You saw it.
I died.
You found the door.
Yeah, I died.
But when I found the door, I revived.
Yes, see I told you that's all we need to do.
Oh, we were back here.
We went.
We were here.
Because there was the mirror.
I need to experience the thing to, you know, educate myself.
Yeah, see it's all.
It's a learning process.
Yeah, it's a learning process.
We found the door.
Respect that.
Okay.
Yeah, we did.
We're learning.
We learned.
Look at that.
See, now we know.
You need a key.
We need to find a red key.
Okay.
We need to find the red key.
Oh my... Oh, there's more drawers.
Okay.
The hour is 1015.
Okay, more pills.
How is this level two?
It's insane.
It's just a level two.
Do you hear that?
At my locker.
Okay, awesome, awesome, awesome.
What is this?
Come on.
Here, here, here, here.
It's gonna kill you, not me.
I'm gonna run away anyway, you know.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna run away.
You can just die alone, you know.
Whoa!
I don't want to die.
Okay, okay.
No, wait, wait, wait.
It's okay.
We'll die together.
Okay.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Oh, wait.
What about we try here?
Come over here.
Here?
Yeah.
Where did you go?
Oh, here.
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah.
Hello?
Okay.
I'm so lost.
I...
Me too.
Where are we?
It's like a maze here.
Yeah, it is the back rooms.
No, we've been here because the door is open.
Oh, wait.
There's more.
Oh, there's flashlight!
Oh, wait.
Is that flashlight?
Let's go!
Oh, my God.
The one thing we've always... We forgot to... Oh, wait.
This was the tutorial.
Wait.
This is the first drawer we found.
Yeah, this is the tutorial.
We missed the flashlight in the tutorial.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
We're so bad.
We missed the...
You gotta carry me, Doki.
You're a professional streamer.
You can't do this to me.
Oh, my God.
We missed the flashlight in the tutorial.
Thank you, Remy.
It's okay.
Now we have flashlight.
Yeah.
Everything's going well.
Okay.
Our mission before we end stream is to get out of here.
Yeah.
True.
We just need to...
Let's go.
Is it okay?
Are we okay?
Yeah.
I think so.
Are we okay?
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I'm a real monkey.
Oh, my God.
He said, find the light.
Find the light.
Oh, my God.
He said, did you hear back?
Welcome back.
He said...
Help.
I died to...
Get out of the fucking room.
There's a monster.
Come.
I can't die like this many times.
Please.
Okay.
He said, when you see the red light, there's a monster.
I got it.
Okay.
When you see red light, there's a monster.
I got it.
Okay.
If you see red...
I heard the fucking sound.
What's that?
That was a jump scare.
Okay.
Wait.
What's that?
There's a box.
What is it?
There's another light.
It's yours.
It's your flashlight.
You died here.
Okay.
Got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Awesome.
Why are we still here?
I feel like I've been here like 20 times.
I don't know where to go.
I'm gonna... Okay.
Let's be brave.
Okay.
For now.
Yeah.
I'm so brave.
Okay.
Dead end.
Wait.
We're here again.
We just got here.
This is... This is where you died three times.
We keep coming back.
Wait.
We keep... We keep coming back to where you died.
TV.
We've been here many times already.
Wait.
We've been... We have never progressed.
We don't progress anywhere.
We're always going back to the same place.
Shut up.
I'm focusing.
Wait.
What is this box?
This is yours.
It's also yours.
Oh, shit.
I picked up some teeth and some...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Here.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
What?
There's nothing here.
It's okay.
We don't have to mind about that.
Now, I really want to get out of my room.
I mean, get out of this room, so...
We need to find... We need to find a new world.
We're back to the TV.
Why are we still always going back to the TV?
Where?
It's the same place.
This is the same place.
Same room, but we died!
Same place!
Oh my god!
We're so lost!
Never ending collab.
Are you ready for the long, long stream?
We're lost!
We keep going back to the same place!
Why did you go back to the same place?
No, oh my god.
We need to figure out a new place to go!
Here!
Here, Yusuf!
I thought you were actually going to Minecraft.
I'm pretty sure we didn't come here.
I know the Minecraft streamers are good at the sense of directions, right?
Okay.
That is not true.
That is absolutely...
No, we've been here!
The red key!
Yeah, this is the red key door!
Let's, you know, we better just stick around here.
And don't go too far from here.
Wait here.
Okay, if you find a painting, look at it closer.
Okay.
Alright.
There must be a new place we haven't gone before.
Yeah.
There has to be one new place.
I refuse to believe that we're...
We found everything.
We need to break the cycle.
Wait, we haven't gone here, I think.
Yusan, Yusan, this way.
Okay.
Here?
I think so.
I don't think we've been here, right?
I bet so.
This is new.
There's no TV here.
Yeah.
There's no TV.
This is new.
Right side here.
Okay.
No, we've opened this door before.
Yeah, yeah.
This is the tutorial!
This is the beginning!
We're back at the beginning!
I'm focusing!
Wait, wait, wait.
Here?
I spent 30 minutes on the tutorial.
You know what?
You shouldn't let me, you know, guide the way for you.
I shouldn't be guiding the way either!
I'm just as lost!
I'm just as lost as you!
I swear to god... this is the TV room!
This is the fucking TV room!
It's the same room again!
Oh my god.
We're back at the TV room!
Is the same...
I hate this game.
I really hate this game.
Wait, wait, wait...
Yusan... Yusan, come here.
Come here.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
This side, this side.
Here, here, here.
This has to be new, right?
I hope so.
I really hope so.
This is the red key room.
I swear to God.
Okay.
Oh my God, we're back in the beginning.
We're back!
We keep looping!
How do we get out of this?
We must find our way out of this loop!
What is this loop?
We can never be a good team, I'll tell you, Doki.
Oh my God.
No, no, no.
It's not us.
It's the game.
You're really bad, Commander.
I'm sorry.
Oh yeah?
You do better.
No!
I found a new room!
It's dead bodies.
I'm like the beginner for most of the game.
I found a new room.
What is this?
At least I didn't find a TV room.
Five times!
It's about missing people were found in Paladin.
Some of the bodies were found in some anomalies.
Look for a VHS tape for more information.
Fisher.
We need a VHS tape.
Okay.
Malcolm Fisher.
Oh!
Okay.
I mean... I... I... Oh!
We...
We put like... I have like body parts on me.
So I think like we put like body parts on them.
Got it.
Like a...
Look at the corpses.
They hide a secret code.
Just pay attention to the body parts.
The blood.
What?
Pay attention to the blood.
Blood type, I guess.
I guess it's like heart.
Oh!
Wait!
Okay.
I have...
The blood is...
The blood.
Okay.
Is there any blood on the leg?
I have a leg.
None of them are on the leg though.
I have foot and... I have a foot and ear.
But none of them are like...
None of them have like head or ears, God.
I have teeth too.
Hey, Nuki.
Look at it.
What?
Insane.
Respect the dead body.
Okay.
What?
Oh!
Okay.
That's scaring me.
Wait.
But how do we...
Do you have any idea for this?
The corp... We need to find...
We need to find a tape.
The tape?
Yeah.
Okay.
Tape on the dead body, right?
Yeah.
Don't touch the smoke because I think the smoke is like dangerous.
Wait.
We need to find the tape and...
Blood matches this to the keypad.
There's no blood here.
Alright.
Let's find a VHS.
Let's go back.
We need to find a VHS tape.
You want the almond milk?
Can we go up?
Here.
No.
There's almond water.
You should take it.
Okay.
It heals your HP.
I think I'm just gonna heal my HP now.
Can I?
Use.
Alright.
Look at the lock on the locker.
What do you mean?
Oh!
One, two... Okay.
Wait.
I figured this out.
I figured it out.
Two, three...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking stupid.
Two, three...
You're so fucking stupid.
I did it.
Wow.
I found a hammer.
We can break vases now.
Awesome.
Okay.
Where are you by the way?
Wait.
Where are you?
You son?
Hello?
Doki?
You son?
I'm gonna die.
Where are you?
I'm inside the locker now.
Get out of the locker!
I just found two enemies already.
Like I don't know.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Where are you?
I don't wanna get out of my...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think they're gone.
It's okay.
There's an enemy next to me.
Why I can't even find you?
I hear your voice.
You died?
No, right?
No.
There's people next to me.
Come over here.
I'm at the bodies.
Why is there red light?
Leave.
What do you mean it's probably gone?
There's still red lights in front of me.
Okay.
I'm very anxious right now.
That's what meds are for.
I'm cured now.
I found a tablet.
I found the tape.
I found the tape?
Yeah.
It was at the horse room.
Come to the...
Come to the body room.
Body room.
Okay.
Wherever you are.
Go back to the body room.
I don't know where you are.
I'm gonna be in the body room.
You have a... You still have your radio?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, God.
The radio is so fucking loud.
Okay.
The dead... The body room, right?
Yeah.
I'm in the body room.
Where was that?
Where was... What do you mean where was that?
It's in the body room.
Where was... Where was that?
I'm just...
I'm still in the body room.
I have so many items on me.
You can't let me die.
I have so many things on me.
Wait.
Hello?
You sign?
You somewhere?
I'm trying to find where was the body room.
I'm trying to find you.
We're up.
Okay.
Here.
There's a buggy.
Why are you hiding inside the locker?
What?
There is... There is a person next to us.
No.
It's gone.
Oh, it's gone?
Yeah.
Oh.
No.
Okay.
It's gone.
What do you mean it's gone?
I see red.
No.
It's there.
It's gone.
You can't say it's gone when I can see the color red.
Okay.
Now it's gone.
It's gone.
It can't be like it's gone when there's red.
Okay.
We need to find the TV.
Wait.
What do I hear?
I heard something drinking.
Okay.
We need to find the TV room.
We found it before 20 times.
We can do it again.
I know, right?
Yeah.
We found it!
Where?
Okay.
No.
There's an enemy in front of us.
It's over here.
Okay.
Yeah.
There's an enemy there.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm proud of us for it.
We can always find the TV room.
I know, right?
Yeah.
We can always find the TV room.
They're gone.
No.
They're not.
I see red.
Really?
If it's red, there's enemies.
What do you mean?
Oh.
My flashlight, it's not working anymore That's why.
Is it?
No.
It is.
It's just when you're close to the enemy, it doesn't work.
Wait.
I just saw your stream.
But, okay.
Okay.
But my- on my screen, it doesn't turn- the light is not turning red.
Wait, what?
It's not turning red?
What's wrong with your screen?
Oh, there's a smoke!
Okay, we can't touch the smoke.
Why is it red again?
Why is it red?
Close that!
Close that door!
Close it!
It's okay.
They wouldn't be here.
It's gone.
It's gone!
Oh!
Can I open the door?
That one- I don't- They're gone.
They're gone.
Okay.
So what was the dead body?
It's still re- Oh, it's a dog!
Wait, wait.
Look at the dog.
I see the dog.
Do you see the dog?
I don't see- I don't see the dog.
It's right there.
I'm looking at it.
Oh my god!
Oh man, the door!
Open the door!
Oh my god!
Oh my- I'm hurt!
I'm hurt!
Did you see the dog?
I'm a sucker!
I'm hurt!
Look at that!
My screen is something!
Right now!
I'm fucking damaged!
I told you!
I told you it was a dog!
You didn't beli- Okay.
You didn't believe me!
You're the one that didn't believe me!
Okay, okay, okay.
I said there was- There was a dog!
Okay.
Let's see if the dog's gone.
Yeah, they're gone.
They're gone.
Okay, we saw the dog, guys.
Happy birthday.
Let's go to the TV!
Let's go!
Yay!
Okay, put it in!
Put it in!
Finally, okay.
Interact.
Okay, use!
Alright.
What does it say?
Alright, so there's nine bodies.
Yeah, that room!
We need to find that room again!
No.
Not again.
Malcolm Fisher.
Where's the nominees?
No, don't... yeah.
I saw that body.
Okay, Malcolm no nose.
Malcolm no nose.
Chat, remember this.
Lena.
No eye.
Okay.
Okay, Lena no eye.
I have foot...
Chad.
Chad!
Oh, I have teeth!
I have teeth on me!
Okay, we need to give Chad his teeth.
And eyes for Lena?
And...
Nose for...
Okay, okay, okay.
I have teeth already.
So let's go back to the body room.
Okay.
Okay, our mission.
We just have to finish this room.
We just have to finish this level.
I like it.
I love it.
The moment we finish this level, we win.
We win.
Okay.
I don't know where to go.
I don't remember where... where was the body room?
Where was the fire?
Me too.
Where was the body room?
Was it like in here?
You, son?
Yeah?
Where are you?
Here, here, here, here.
Where is here?
Come over here.
Here, here, here, here.
Okay.
Alright, I think it was like in this corridor?
I hope so.
I think?
I can't move properly.
Oh my god.
I'm seriously lack of stamina.
Okay.
Yeah, I found it.
I found it.
Okay.
It was Chad, right?
Wait, there's a red.
There's red.
This is Lena.
Okay.
We need to find Chad.
Chad is teeth.
Marco.
Celine.
Frank.
Robert.
Welcome.
Okay, I found Chad.
The last one.
Nice.
I just put it here?
Mm.
I do it?
Okay, I got teeth.
Alright.
We need...
We need to find an eye and a nose.
Okay.
How do we find them?
Okay, we just gotta look.
Alright.
Okay.
Did you go this way yet?
Nope.
I guess.
Alright.
We didn't...
Did we go here yet?
No, I don't think so.
That's just a locker.
It's just a normal locker.
Normal locker, you know?
But it could be a trap.
Where the fuck is the nose?
Wait, there's red here.
Who's over there though?
I don't know where we haven't gone.
Want me to go there?
I don't know.
I'm so lost.
Where do we not go?
I can never tell.
I heard the sound.
I heard the noise.
Do I have footsteps?
I'm just gonna get myself a ball.
I'm just gonna go.
No!
It was not my fault that we did that.
Was not my fault they're not fast enough for the locker.
Was not my fault!
How could I?
Whoever gets the locker first win.
They could have...
They could have picked their own locker.
They could have found it.
I did not abandon you some.
I saw a locker and I went for it.
Look I have the...
I have the...
the ear and the legs.
This is important.
I have the ears and the legs.
I can't die.
Exactly.
Don't need to outrun the monster.
I just gotta be faster than the other person.
I just need to be faster.
Exactly.
That was horrible.
What do you mean?
I found the locker.
That was horrible.
I said...
I'm scared.
I'm like anxious now.
Maybe...
We can...
Come here.
We haven't been here.
Where did you go?
What is that?
I have the hammer.
Nice.
I have screws on it by the way.
Yeah.
Wait.
I don't have the hammer.
Do you have the hammer?
I don't have it actually.
Really?
Yeah.
Let me check my email.
You have it?
I didn't pick it up.
No.
I don't have it.
Wait.
I do.
I'm dumb.
How do I...
I?
Wait.
One.
Yeah.
Okay.
How do I bring my hammer out?
How do I?
Swing it.
It won't let me bring my hammer out.
I'm scroll wheeling.
You have to equip it.
Equip it.
I did.
Why?
Okay.
You do.
You're so good.
You picked up the hammer.
Okay.
Let me try that.
Equip.
That's right.
Okay.
How do I use that?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
How do you use it?
Yeah.
How do we use that?
How do you use it?
Yeah.
Wait.
Interact.
Maybe you can break something.
Wait.
Yeah.
How do you use it?
You saw it.
Oh wait.
E.
Press E.
Then I.
Then scroll wheel.
Um...
What did you say?
E.
I.
And then scroll wheel.
Okay.
So I have to equip first, right?
Yeah.
E.
I.
Yeah.
Scroll.
No.
It's not.
It's not working.
I told you it wasn't easy.
Okay.
Fine.
I'll figure it out.
E.
I.
Oh my god.
I'm so... I figured it out.
I'm so proud of ourselves.
Okay.
Wait.
Something.
Did you hide inside the locker?
Okay.
I'm safe.
Awesome.
Okay.
I'm safe.
Where are you?
Okay.
I'm just... I'm just breaking everything right now.
What is that?
What is this?
I don't know.
I found the red key!
Noice.
What's that?
What?
It's me.
Why were you screaming?
I'm in front of you.
You don't see me?
I see you.
But why were you screaming?
No.
I'm happy.
Oh.
You're happy.
Okay.
I thought something happened.
I was like... something...
There's a dog.
I'm just screaming.
Yusa, where are you?
Nogie.
I'm inside.
Are you okay?
You're inside the locker?
Okay.
It's gone.
Yeah.
We dodged it.
We did it.
We're a team.
It's fine.
Get out.
It's not fine.
He's in front of me.
It's fine.
It's not right.
Run.
Find a locker.
Are you okay?
Yusa, are you okay?
It's gone.
Oh my god.
We're so good at this game.
It's not okay.
Okay.
I need to drink my almond water.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
I'm here.
Okay.
I'm gonna break some more vases.
Hammer.
More violence.
Break everything.
Nice.
Okay.
I have the red key.
We got...
Oh, you want the anxiety pills?
Do you need some?
I need it.
Yeah.
Here.
There's some more.
I ran out of my...
I ran out of my anxiety pills.
Oh my god.
The dog left.
Okay.
There has...
Is there anything else?
There's more anxiety pills here.
I need it.
Yeah.
Leave us alone!
We just wanted to eat our fish!
What's the dog doing?
Leave us alone!
I'm alive, alive.
Are you alive?
Is the dog still there?
No.
Just do it.
If the dog's there, we're gonna get out of here.
It's there.
You see that?
It's just right there.
I don't have enough almond water!
You see that?
I do!
I'm looking at it right now!
Leave!
They're looking at me right now!
They're staring at me!
Why did you do that to me?
Why?
Oh!
Oh, the water fucking died!
What was that?
What did you do that?
What do you mean?
Explanation.
I didn't do anything!
I'm just trying to...
Almond water!
Oh, the water fucking died!
The water fucking died!
What the fuck?
Stay there!
You...
Oh my god.
Monster magnet.
Shut up!
Is there anything else in the vases?
Get out!
Get away!
I can't!
I just...
But I wanna find... I wanna know if there's anything else!
My sight!
Is there anything else in the vases?
That's the only reason why I'm breaking them!
Why is he still there?
Leave!
The dog fucking loved me so bad!
Oh my god!
Okay.
But there's one more vase!
Oh, it's just a key.
Why did Nani break that many vases?
Okay, is he gone?
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Okay, I need to drink my almond water again.
Okay, we can leave now!
We have the key!
Awesome!
I'm happy that we're...
Okay, come here!
Oh!
It's still here!
Leave!
Leave me alone!
What the fuck?
That's so funny!
He's still here!
No, it's gone!
No, he's literally still here!
I'm looking at him!
Don't worry!
No, no, get out!
You know...
Dude, just... the fucking... the scream from...
I like how I heard the scream from the distance!
It's like...
Oh no!
No, it's not!
He's not here!
Wow!
Oh my god!
Is it...
Is it gone now?
Is the dog gone?
More almond water!
I love my almond water!
You son?
Come, he's gone!
He's gone for real!
You son?
I can't do it!
You son, come over here!
Get out of the room!
Leave us alone!
Oh my god, leave!
What a lot of...
Leave!
I can't get- Leave!
You son!
Just...
Leave!
We just wanna finish this level.
This is all we want.
Just fucking leave us alone!
Oh my god!
I'm just here forever!
Where are you?
Yusak, get out of the room!
Oh my god!
Why is it still here?
Oh my god.
Yusak, I'm gonna leave the room.
Yusak!
Yusak, run!
Run to me!
Yusak, run to me!
Run to the vase!
Run out of the vases!
Get out of the vase room!
Oh my god!
Dog!
What
the fuck is this?
What the fuck is this?
Dog!
Fuck out of here!
Oh my god!
I can't see any shit!
Anxiety pill?
Oh my god!
I used all of my almond water!
That's insane!
Almond water!
Save me!
Please!
Look it!
I see you!
Get out of the vase room!
Just leave that room!
I can't find it.
Get out of the vase room!
Please!
Yusak!
I wanna leave!
Yusak, I wanna leave that!
Get out!
Get out?
Get out of the vase room!
Leave the vase room!
Leave that room!
I swear I'll leave!
Wait, I heard...
I heard this.
Wait.
I heard something.
Base room.
What are you talking about?
Just leave that room!
Get out of that room!
Get out of the area!
Please!
Wait!
Ducky?
Where are you?
Okay, I'm in the chest box right now.
I'm in the upper chest.
Okay, we're out!
We're out!
We did it!
Yusak!
Turn around!
I'm here!
Okay, no!
Let's go!
You don't have to use the radio!
We did it!
We got out of the room!
That's all I wanted!
I just wanted to leave that room!
I...
We're out of the room!
I used the ball thing that I'm killing now.
I'm in the water.
This is insane.
Here, there's more anxiety.
I found a hand!
And I found Almond Water.
Oh my god!
We're finally out of the room!
We did it!
We're out of the fucking room!
This game's fucking hard, yo!
Yeah!
Why does everybody love to play this game?
It's fucking hard!
Yusak, I just need you to know...
We're on easy mode!
No!
Oh my god!
This is easy mode!
We spent almost an hour to...
Oh!
Read note.
Radiation room.
There's a locked door.
We don't have...
We don't have a radiation...
We don't have anything to protect ourselves.
We need the protection suits.
Yeah, yeah.
Come over here.
Oh my god.
This is a tutorial and it's easy!
Radiation hosu.
Oh my god.
I didn't want to tell you until now.
We've been on easy this entire time.
I don't believe that.
We are 100% on easy mode.
Okay, we need to figure out how to find the door.
We need to figure out how to find the door.
Oh my god.
Did you see the red light?
No, I didn't see that.
I think there's a bug on my game screen.
There's a red light.
No.
It's not there.
It's fine.
Okay.
Okay, here we're good.
We're good.
We need to find the red door.
Okay, we're back in the body's room.
This is not the door room.
But I remember Yeah?
The red door is just...
It's supposed to be around here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'll follow you.
You find it.
You're so good at finding the door.
No.
I am really good at dodging dogs.
But you found the dog.
You found the door like three times before.
How did we do that?
I don't know.
I'm following you.
How did we do that?
I don't remember.
I don't...
Is it here?
I don't know.
I'm just following you.
No, this is the tutorial.
We're back in the...
I also think you're really good at finding the tutorial.
Here, here, here.
You know why?
Can I make some excuse?
Oh my... wait, wait.
There is the bug on my game.
Wait, I can...
I can spray paint and...
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, how do I spray paint?
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait.
How do I spray paint?
How do I use this?
Wait, look, look, I can...
Oh my god, yeah.
What is it for?
I can use this to tell us where to go.
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait.
V, change image.
Okay.
That's awesome.
How do I do this?
Beware, exit.
Look at that, look at that.
Look at this.
Yeah, yeah, how do you...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, we should have done this.
Why did we do this?
Why did...
Why was it so hard?
Oh my god.
Why were we so stupid?
We didn't know how to play this game.
Okay, alright.
We figured it out.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
Alright, we figured out how to use this.
Okay, the moment we find the door...
Wait, what?
Can we splay this...
hallway just in case?
How do I do that?
I don't know, you're the one that did it.
Just to make sure.
Why do we need to spray this hallway?
What is this hallway gonna be?
Just to make sure that we're not getting lost again.
Okay, but they don't have...
Why are they all ones?
I don't know.
Wait, it's not here.
This wasn't it.
We figured out how to use the spray paint though.
Yeah, awesome.
You know you can change the picture.
No, I just wanna make sure we've been here already.
You know?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Everything is just one.
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
You suck!
Is your son dead?
I don't know guys.
Do you think your son is okay?
Guys.
Do you think they're okay?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
You son!
Find the door!
Find the...
The white...
Look.
I'm not gonna say that it's my fault.
All I'm saying is that...
The locker was right there.
And either of us could have got it.
It was a 50-50 in getting the door.
It's not my fault.
That was your fault.
Are you okay?
How is it my fault?
No.
No!
I'm not okay!
How is that my fault?
You did it!
You were the one that didn't get the door!
The locker!
I died four times already in this round.
You know?
Yeah!
That's... that sucks!
But that's not my fault.
I don't think it's this way.
I think...
I think it's like...
Somewhere in one of these corridors.
Maybe this one?
Okay.
No, this is the body one.
This is the body... Maybe this one?
Lisa.
Where'd you go?
This one, this one, this one.
Wait, this is the one where you spray-painted one.
So it's definitely not this.
Not here.
Is it here?
No, this is the... It's the TV.
We keep going to the TV.
Wow, you're memorizing the map.
Nice.
Okay.
There's red, there's red light.
There's red light, there's red light.
You saw there's red light there.
There's red light.
I really hate it!
You know, I think there's the game bug on my screen.
I think so too, cause...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, I see him.
I see him.
He's like walking over.
It's gone, it's fine.
It's fine.
Woah, you see that?
You see that?
Yeah, do you see it?
Oh wait, I'm getting crazy looking at it.
Don't look at it!
Don't look at it by the way.
There's like...
Oh, it's gone, it's gone.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like, you see that?
Wait, never.
I heard something instead.
There's a horse room.
Wait, did you finish the horse?
Yeah, we finished the horse.
We did, we did.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In this room, we got the screwdriver.
Wait, there's a...
Wait, I found a nose!
Yeah, there's a nose.
Do you need albin water?
There's albin water right here.
Freeze, freeze, freeze.
Yeah, there's albin water.
Oh my god, we got the nose.
Awesome.
Alright, we're figuring it out.
I didn't know that that was a nose.
I thought that was something else.
Okay, we were here before.
I remember this.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the red door?
I don't remember!
We found it so many times!
Here.
Okay, here.
This is the dog room.
We don't need to go back to the dog room.
Oh, yo.
That's the dog room.
Okay.
We don't have the... go to the clock.
We don't have the clock arms, though.
Guys.
I don't have the arms for the clock.
Okay, we have the nose.
Where the fuck...
Alright, chat.
Do you guys remember where the red door is?
It's to you.
Chat, wait, wait, I can't breathe.
Don't look, don't look, don't look.
There's a face in there.
There is a face in there.
No, I don't see that.
I don't see that.
He's still there, he's still there, he's still there.
He's still there.
Don't look at it.
Are we gonna go insane if we look at their face?
Yeah, yeah.
If we look at the face, we go crazy.
Okay, it's gone, it's gone.
Okay.
I'm pretty sure... I found the body room.
Guys!
Who has no nose?
Okay.
Eyes.
Just eyes.
I bet, you know, we're gonna use the red key and open the door and there's gonna be the eyes.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Right?
I think so.
It has to be because our next one is the key.
We just don't know where the door is.
This one, this one.
We can't find the fucking door.
This guy, this guy.
Alright, got it.
I got Malcolm.
Okay.
Alright.
One more.
Okay, wait, wait.
Mark this.
Mark this area.
How far are we?
We should mark this area to remember the... Can you change the picture?
Okay, okay, okay.
Change the picture to something?
Okay.
How about this?
Can't all be ones.
It can be, yeah.
Change picture.
Change color.
Wait, wait.
They can't all be ones.
Okay.
That's still a one.
But okay.
How about that?
I guess so.
Good enough, right?
That's good enough, yeah.
That works, that works.
It's not a nose.
That's for sure.
I'm trying to figure out...
We know that we've been there.
Yeah, at least we know that's the fucking...
Where the fuck is the door?
I can't...
We need something.
We need someone who's actually a genius to play this game.
We need to find the door!
Where is the door?
Door!
Where is the...
I'm at the tutorial.
Oh my god.
Come on, follow me, follow me.
Just follow me.
Just trust me.
It's gonna work.
Okay, I'll follow you.
I'll trust you.
I trust you.
Okay.
It's gonna work.
Yeah.
I'm running out of my stamina.
I'm trusting you right now.
It's red.
Yeah.
Okay.
We did it!
Oh my god!
I knew I could trust...
I knew I could... Told you!
You always know where the door is!
We should've followed you!
I should've believed myself, not you.
You should've believed yourself!
Okay, they said... Look at the painting.
There might be a code.
They said the painting has a code.
There might be a code inside.
How do we look?
I don't know.
How do we... How?
How?
How do we figure it out?
They're like, the painting has a code.
I don't see any numbers here.
I don't see anything.
Did you just...
Wait, I see it!
I see it!
What?
Come here, come here, come here!
Look at this!
I'm looking at it.
You're not seeing it?
Like, this angle.
It's like red!
This angle.
I don't see that.
You don't see it?
Wait!
Yeah, you see it?
Oh!
Okay, I see... What does it say?
Is that an A?
What is this?
Is it... Is it L?
What is that?
L.
A.
L?
Okay.
L, A.
What is that spell?
I don't know.
I am not a namespeaker.
I don't know what that spells either.
Don't worry, chat will know.
Wait, what is that?
I got fingers!
LMAO!
LMAO?
Is it this?
Guys, is it LMAO?
Guys!
Is it LMAO?
Oh, it's moral.
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
It's moral.
Okay, guys.
Thank you.
It's LMAO.
Oh my god.
I still don't know how 1987 was the answer.
I'm gonna miss myself.
And I'll never know.
Moral.
Okay.
Where the fuck is L?
L.
Oh, here it is.
Nice.
Whoa.
Oh yeah, get the almond water.
I got fused.
No, I can't take it anymore.
I got too much water.
Oh, you got too much water.
Okay, I got it.
I got a few fuses.
And moon jelly.
Pick up moly jelly.
What the fuck do I do with the fuses?
In the fuse box.
Okay.
Wait, but like, what do we...
Where do we go next?
I feel like we did so many things.
What else are we missing?
Chat!
I don't know anymore.
I don't know what to do anymore.
Where was the fuse room?
There was a fuse room?
There was?
Was there?
I don't know.
I don't think I've ever seen the fuse room.
I've never seen it before.
So I think we don't have to go...
We don't have to come back here anymore, isn't it?
I don't know.
I don't think...
You know what?
What about we just gonna stick in that room first?
But like...
We're...
Let's go back.
But like, what do we do?
We need to find clock hands.
But where the fuck are the clock hands?
We're gonna figure it out later.
It's at 1.
Okay.
Oh, we still need the body parts now.
We need to figure out all the...
All the...
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Where was the red room again?
I just wanna make sure to...
Use the spray can to, you know...
This is it.
There's a monster here.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
AHHHHH!
Are you okay?
Chat!
Yeah?
I'm still alive!
Yay!
Okay.
I wanna make sure we didn't miss anything.
I'm gonna go back in.
Yeah.
I wanna be sure we didn't miss anything in the...
In this room.
Cause I don't wanna come back here.
And this way is pretty simple.
I mean...
Yeah, these are just lockers, so...
There's a cat here.
Hello, little kitty.
Yeah, there's nothing here.
There's nothing in the drawers, too.
Alright, we didn't miss anything.
Nice.
Awesome.
Wait!
What is that?
Is that a porn?
No, it's a cat!
It's a pussy!
Pussy in my...
My pussy in bio.
Okay.
Alright, we got... What do we do next, chat?
We don't know where the claw cans are!
What's in your inventory?
Do you have any claw cans?
Wait, let me check.
No, I have screwdriver, uh, splay can, I have moly jelly...
Okay, I have that, too.
Yeah, I have all that.
I don't know where else to go.
I feel like we went so...
Wait, okay, I'll fo...
The dog's here!
The dog's to our right.
The dog's there!
The dog's here!
I saw the dog!
We're back in the tutorial.
We're back!
Oh, it's back in the tutorial!
I'm out of here!
Seriously!
Okay.
Okay, follow me!
I'm just gonna try my wild I'm just gonna try my success.
We'll never get out of the tutorial!
Not here, not here, not here, not here.
Not here, not here, not here.
I'm running out of pills!
I'm running out!
What about here?
Where will we leave the tutorial?
Okay, it's a radiation room here again.
Yeah, but we can't go to the radiation room because we'll get radiated.
Let me mark it.
Let me mark the radiation room just in case.
How do we know if it's the radiation room?
You know...
Equip, use...
Okay.
Oh!
We can find the...
The... the vase room.
Remember the vase room?
Why is the dog always here?
Why is
the dog always here?
Why is the dog always here?
Oh, God!
Leave us alone!
Please!
I don't have a lot of Alvin wine!
I don't have a lot of water!
Eeeeee!
I just wanted to get out of the tutorial!
Why is the tutorial so high?
Alright.
We figured this out.
I'm in the chest room.
I found the clock hands!
Okay, guys.
What is the numbers?
We don't need a figure.
We can do this together.
Yes, we don't need the clue.
Get us out of the tutorial.
Guys, we don't need the clue.
We don't need to actually solve this.
Just hand me the numbers right now.
It can't be 1015!
That's the fucking clock!
It can't!
I knew it was a 1015.
There's no way it's 1987!
Again!
Please, please!
Please!
Oh my God!
Look here!
Okay, in the chest room, right?
I found you!
There's red outside.
You should come in.
I see red light.
We're trying to figure out the passcode for this.
I don't know why I'm in the end room.
It's not 1980!
Everyone's like, it's 1980!
I swear to God it's not 1987!
I swear to God!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
I fucking knew it was a 1987!
Okay, I found the clock hat!
Do you remember where the horse is?
Yeah, boom!
Here?
Wait, why is my flashlight...
Oh, I cut it off.
Around here!
Around here?
Are you sure?
I don't think that's...
No, it's not here.
I think...
I don't think that's...
I think it's back here.
I'm pretty sure.
I found it.
I knew it.
Yay!
I was correct!
I don't think you knew the way.
No, you were not correct.
That was absolutely...
You were not correct.
There was no way.
I was halfway correct.
No, you were not.
Come on, you can solve this game alone.
I swear to God.
Wait, how do we...
How do we do the clock?
How do we...
Rotate it?
I'm trying!
I can't get it!
Oh, it's back here!
Wait, what?
Oh, back?
Okay.
Where was it?
Oh!
Okay.
Is it 10?
It's 10.
Is it on 10?
It's on 10.
Okay, is this on 5?
Let me know when it's on 5.
Okay, so the short one is on 10.
And the long one is on 5 right now.
Oh, okay.
Is the long one on 10 yet?
No, wait, wait.
The long one is on 5, right?
The long one is on 5.
Yeah, okay.
Is this on 10?
No, 7.
10?
5.
3, 2.
Oh my God, where the fuck is...
Just go, almost there.
12, 11, 10!
Okay, this is short.
Is this on 15?
The short one, right?
I need long one.
Long.
Long, long.
I need 15.
I heard something!
12.
I'm hearing something!
Shh, it's the dog.
3, 2, 1.
12.
11.
10.
9.
Where the fuck is 15?
7.
Wait, 15, 3!
You gotta put a...
Put it on 3.
3, 3.
Okay.
2, 1.
1, 1, 2.
3, there we go.
Okay.
Oh my God.
We're asking such a stupid question.
Wait, that's the short one!
The long one!
The short one has to be on 10!
And the long one has to be on 3!
The short one is on 2 right now.
Okay, I need the short one to be on 10.
I...
11.
That's so stupid.
10.
Okay, now 10.
We're so...
Oh my God, we're both so dumb.
1.
2.
3.
Yeah, we did it!
Yay!
What the fuck?
You're pretty bad at listening.
What do you mean?
Okay, 3, 7, 0, 8.
Okay, we gotta go back to the dog room.
3, 7, 0, 8.
Oh my God.
The dog room.
Here, right?
Here?
It's supposed to be here.
Right?
Here, yeah, this way, this way.
Oh my God.
AHHHHH!
Ooooooooh.
Oh.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah.
Oh.
You so...
Where are you?
I used the mobile thing.
Where are you now?
Oh.
I'm...
I'm freaking out.
Are you fucking kidding...
Everything is trying to kill me.
Leave me the fuck alone!
Oh.
Is it gone now?
Is it...
Guys, I don't think it was gone.
I don't think...
Guys, I have all the good thi...
I have all the stuff right now.
I can't die.
If I die, all of my stuff will be gone.
Look, this is important.
I have a lot of the stuff right now.
Okay?
I need to make sure I don't die.
I need to make sure...
Are you okay?
Are you alive?
You're alive!
Okay, let's go to the...
Let's go to the dog room.
This game is not okay.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta run to the dog room.
Okay.
We're here.
Okay, 3... 7...
I got this.
3...
7...
0...
8.
Huh?
Oh, okay.
It just didn't register.
Oh my god.
We got pliers.
What the fuck were the pliers...
What are the pliers for?
Progress!
We got progress.
But what is it for though?
What is this for?
I have no idea.
The first...
First...
Open!
No, no, no!
Close the door!
Why did you close the door on yourself?
Did I do that all by myself?
I thought you were roasting me.
No, you closed it yourself!
I ruined it this whole time.
Just all by my own.
I was watching you close the door on yourself.
What the fuck?
Okay, let's go.
What are we missing?
Like an eye.
We're missing an eye.
We need to find...
What do I use the pliers for though?
I don't know.
Okay, we don't have to come back here ever again.
We're done here.
Oh my god.
Chad, help!
What are we missing?
Chad, help.
Chad, please.
Where do we need to go?
We went through everything!
Chad!
Did we go through all that?
Where were you heading right now?
I left... There's no... There's a smiley face near us.
Oh my god.
That's the red door.
That's the body parts.
These are body parts.
We don't need to be here.
Oh, mirror room!
Mirror room!
Wait, they said go to the...
I'm in the mirror room.
We have to go to the mirror room.
I forgot.
Okay, I believe in you.
You can find the mirror room.
Okay, six cents.
That's like the one room we always find.
Believe my sense.
I believe in you.
Yeah.
That's the what's not there.
That's the dog room.
Yeah.
Well, we're here.
No, that's the tutorial.
Here.
Come here.
It's near the tutorial room.
Because I know it's near the tutorial room.
That's the one room we're really good at.
Well.
Here.
Got it?
Smiley face.
Smiley.
It's not here.
That's the dog room again.
We're back in the dog room.
We're back in the dog.
Where the fuck is the mirror room?
Okay.
Tutorial.
This is tutorial.
I remember.
Okay.
They said.
This is tutorial.
We're literally at the tutorial again.
Why are we so lost?
For real.
100% if there were two more people, we would have definitely solved this a lot faster.
we would have definitely solved this a lot faster.
As a duo, we're so fast.
It's the tutorial!
It's the elevator!
Look for the ones.
You sad?
Where are you?
Scared!
Where is... I'm at the mirror room!
Come here!
Where are you?
I'm back in the tutorial!
Come to me!
There was a monster!
I'm at the beginning!
Oh my god!
Where are you?
I'm at the beginning!
Find the ones you sad!
Find your...
Find your ones!
You sad?
Hello?
Where are you?
I'm at the ones!
I need my taxi!
Come to the mirror room!
I don't know where the mirror room is!
I believe in device!
I don't believe in myself!
Pick me up!
Uber!
Now is your time to be independent!
Now!
I don't want to be independent!
You have to be independent!
No!
It's too scary!
How dare you.
You can spoil it like this.
I found you!
I'm here!
How does this...?
Ok...
I did it.
Are you proud of me?
Okay, we're at the mirror room guys.
What do we do at the mirror room?
What do we do?
We're at the mirror room!
We're at the mirror room.
Yeah, what do we do?
Smashy smashy time?
How do I smash it?
Go through the mirror.
Wait, how about the hammer?
I don't know.
I can't get the hammer.
No, it's not the hammer.
It's not?
Smash.
It says smash.
You can?
Where?
How?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure.
Smash the mirror.
How do you smash it?
Oh, body parts first.
But where's the eye?
We can't find the eye!
How do we find the eye?
We don't know where the eye is!
We don't know where the eye is.
I'm just gonna make sure to mark the path.
Yeah.
Yeah, use... okay.
Okay, where the fuck's the eye?
The previous subject was found without a mirror.
Okay, wait, what the fuck?
That's the wrong...
I shouldn't be using this image.
What the fuck?
Oh my... oh, I hate that.
Oh my god, I fucking... do you remember that last vase we never smashed?
That had the eye in it.
Nope.
I can't believe it.
Okay, we gotta find the vases again.
The dog room.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe... I...
Oh wait, did you mark it to tell us that that's the eye?
This is the eye... mirror room?
I think that was the... that's not the good place to mark.
Okay.
Okay, here.
Mirror room?
Okay, mirror room?
Okay.
Mirror room.
Okay, it's pretty obvious now.
I can't...
Now we know where the mirror room is, Elsa.
I can't believe the last vase was where the fucking eye is.
No, this is not where the vase is.
It's like back here.
We need to find the... you remember the horse room?
We need to get there.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, where did you go?
Youssef?
Here?
Youssef, where are you?
Come here, come here.
Here.
What about here?
Horse room?
Here.
Here?
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, it's not here.
No, no, it's here.
This is the exit.
And now we need to figure out where the dog room is.
We need to figure out where the fuck is the dog room.
Okay, we're at the tutorial.
We're at the tutorial.
That's the tutorial.
I think it's here.
Right?
No, that's the dead end.
I remember the dog room was somewhere there.
I mean, not the dog room though.
I mean, the horse room was just near around the tutorial.
This is the tutorial.
This is the elevator.
Here?
No, this is the elevator.
Elevator.
Okay, follow me, follow me.
Again.
I'm gonna use my sixth sense again.
Okay.
All right.
I believe in your... No, it's this way.
Your sixth sense.
Here, here, here, here.
Just follow me.
Oh my god.
I trust your sixth sense.
I'm not smart enough to play... Okay, this is the mirror room.
This is the mirror room.
I'm not smart enough to play this game, seriously.
Wait, why was this red?
Why did we mark this red?
Red door?
Yeah, the door.
The lead door.
This is the door.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, or was it the... No, this is the door.
Okay.
This room.
Here.
No, this is the mirror room!
Here?
Oh, this one!
Is that...?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
This is it!
Wait, why is it red?
Okay, this is it!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
And then we go straight down.
Okay.
Oh my god...
It's right there.
I heard something.
No, he's right in front of us.
He's like in the walls.
Alright.
This is it.
I swear to fucking god.
There was no fucking eye.
You liars.
You fuckers lied to me.
There was no eye!
You fucking...
Where the fuck is the eye?
Oh my god.
It was not the last base.
I fucking knew it.
Then where is it?
Where is the last base?
Where is...
Where is the last body?
Oh my god.
How many dead bodies?
How many dead bodies are there?
I trusted you chat.
Locker with shells but we opened every locker.
Oh wait, you died.
Wait, you died?
I died.
You died?
Sorry, I stole your screwdriver.
I didn't realize you...
Yeah, I have screwdriver.
I didn't realize you died.
Wait, did we open the TV drawers already?
The radioactive room?
That's where the eye is?
But we have no protection suits.
Yeah, we don't have any protection suits.
Can we just walk in without the protection room?
Can we just walk through?
But they're like...
Okay, there's a locked door that only will open the radiation of the room is on low.
To achieve this is a class D.
It won't limit it but it will decrease the radiation.
Don't go in there.
Steal the suits.
No, wait.
Wait, you can steal it?
Yeah, maybe you can interact with this guy?
I don't know.
How do we take his suit?
Oh, everybody was like don't go through.
Don't go through the room.
Yeah.
They're like don't do it.
Okay, thank you.
We won't do that.
We won't go.
Thank you.
Don't trust... where's the eyes then?
I swear to God.
You screwdriver.
Wait, screwdriver?
Oh, no, I don't have the screwdriver.
No, I have it.
I have it.
I took it.
Okay.
Alright.
What else?
Oh my God.
Okay, we need to figure out...
We need to figure out where the...
Where the fuck is the eye?
Where is the protection suit?
Where's the eye?
Where is it?
I don't...
I don't know where it is.
It's in the...
Enter.
Check in that room.
Take his eye.
You guys are pretty random.
Oh my God.
We're never gonna progress.
I told you guys that...
We'll never know what's in...
Oh.
It's red.
Why is it red?
I don't know.
Is there a enemy?
From the mirror.
Where...
Where is it?
No, I don't believe that.
It's in the room.
I don't believe that.
What do you mean?
I looked at all the lockers.
What in the wall?
Did we miss...
There is a locker next to...
Not too many trolls.
Wait.
There's a locker next to the red door.
Did we miss out the eye?
Did you guys hear the backseat?
Okay.
The red room drawer.
Find us the red room.
Oh my god.
Where was it?
Find the red room.
The red door.
Where was it?
It's not there.
Where are you going?
Oh.
It's apparently random.
It's...
Okay.
It's random and they say it's usually in the locker.
Oh, it's random.
It's in the locker or a drawer.
Okay.
We're missing a drawer.
All right.
We might die here because it's...
There's a red light but I don't know where the...
Where the monster is right now.
Okay.
Oh my god.
We need to find...
Can we just go in?
Yeah.
It's okay.
Okay.
We need to find the red door.
The red door.
Okay.
I believe in you.
Just follow me.
It's okay.
Following you?
I'll be responsible.
Don't worry.
This is the dog room.
I thought the red room is near the dog room.
No.
This is the dog room.
It's not...
I know it's not here.
It's not here.
Not there?
It's...
It's not here.
This is the dog room.
I think this is the...
B, why are we back at the dog room?
We're never leaving.
Go back.
Come back.
I don't wanna go to Minnesota!
Oh no, no!
Is he gone?
Let me check.
He's gone!
Okay, okay, okay.
Go look at the... we live in the lockers for now.
Live in the locker!
Okay, it's gone.
It's gone.
Is it gone?
We gotta find the eye!
You saw it!
Is it still red?
Just run!
Why the fuck let us...
Free us, please!
I... I just wanna finish the tutorial!
Why is this the hardest level ever?
What is wrong with this game?
I have the last...
It's the anxiety pill!
You son, where... where are you?
You son!
Okay, this is the... the body room.
Wait, there's more anxiety pills.
Let's go.
If I close my eyes...
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god, I lost...
You son, where are you?
You son!
What if I just die?
I lost...
You know what?
What if I just die and find the fu...
I swear to god.
I sw...
I think the best thing I can do right now is I die and I find the eye.
Oh, I found the fucking...
I found the red door.
Just kill me.
Just kill...
End this!
There's no eye here anyway!
Okay.
Alright.
We got... we can find... we're gonna find the eye.
I swear I'm gonna find the fucking eye.
I'm gonna find the eye while I'm dead.
I'm gonna find the eye while I'm dead!
It's the only way!
Awesome.
Okay, you're there.
Okay, I see your shadow.
Good luck.
I'm...
There's no timer!
I'm gonna find the eye!
I'm gonna find the eye while I'm dead!
I can't see items when I'm dead?
Then what...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I can't even see items when I'm dead.
I...
Oh my god.
This is a fucking hell.
This is...
No!
I can't find items while I'm dead.
Okay.
What I learned...
Wait.
Wait, where's the mirror room?
Did we check the TV fucking drawers?
I swear to fucking god, if we never like looked into the...
Looked into the drawers in the TV mirror room, I swear to fucking god, I would be so mad.
I would be so fucking mad.
I...
I don't know where the tea...
Okay.
I swear to god.
Okay, all the drawers are open.
Alright, all the drawers are open.
Thank fucking god.
I...
I'm trying to...
Did we ever open this?
I swear to god, did we ever open this?
I swear.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh my fucking god.
Okay, yes I did.
Alright, I'm back at the tutorial.
I know, I need to revive, but I need to figure out where the fuck am I first.
Okay, this is the revive room.
Where's the...
This is the mirror room.
I keep going back to the mirror room.
I keep...
This is the red room.
Okay.
Red room is here.
Okay, red room is here.
I swear.
Where is it?
I'm slowly...
I'm going for the red room.
I'm going crazy right now.
Where the...
Okay.
Radiation room.
I'm going to check the radiation.
I want to know what the fuck is in the radiation room.
I'm going to make sure I've...
Okay, those are just lockers.
Okay, I was going to be like, I swear.
I swear to fucking god.
If there was like nothing...
Did we ever open the drawers in the clock room?
Did we?
Oh my god.
Guys!
Did we?
Oh, yes.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I just needed to know that.
All right.
What was in this room?
It was a gas mask, a bucket.
Wait.
I couldn't look at items while dead.
What the fuck did you guys mean when you said I couldn't?
The fuck are these?
Okay, radiation room.
So many doors.
Oh my god.
There's...
There's like crutches.
There's a fucking teddy bear.
How do I get out of here?
How do I...
Oh, those are not items.
You mean they're not items?
They just exist?
I don't know how to get out of here now.
Must be...
Where am I?
Okay, here it is.
All right.
We're going to find the...
We're going to get out of here.
Those items don't count.
That's a puzzle.
The moment we find the eyeball and finish the fucking body parts...
I'm...
We're...
This...
It's over.
Oh my god.
Where's the door?
It just revived me.
Okay.
How do I get revived?
Where is it?
Where's the heartbeat?
Heartbeat!
I hear the heartbeat, but where?
Where is it?
Follow the trail.
Follow the light trail.
I'm here.
I'm back!
Why?
Oh my god, I'm back!
Don't worry!
When you want to revive, you gotta follow the light.
Yeah, I was trying to see a locker that we didn't open.
I was trying to find a locker.
We already did the red door though.
It's not the red door.
This one's the red door.
Yeah, but like...
We have to...
The horse room, right?
We opened all of these.
It's like in a drawer!
The eye is in a drawer or a locker that we didn't open!
But we opened everything!
We opened everything!
Where?
Okay.
TV room.
TV room lockers.
Body room.
A tiny offshoot near the vase room.
What?
A tiny offshoot near the vase room?
Which has a drawer with the eyes...
The vase room has two spots the eye can be.
Okay.
We need to fix...
We checked the TV room.
Okay.
The TV room lockers, right?
We did all that.
Let's go to the...
I didn't know we opened all the drawers there.
We opened the body room.
Okay.
We can try the vase room again.
Maybe it's in the vase room.
Where is the vase room?
Okay, follow me.
Sixth sense.
Alright.
There has to...
We're gonna go...
We're gonna do a checklist.
We'll do a little checklist.
We'll do vase room first.
This is the first room.
This is the...
Okay.
Elevator.
The first...
It's fine.
The first thing we find is...
That means we can start from the beginning again.
Oh, my God.
Whenever you're lost, you have to review yourself, then you have to remember how did you actually start.
I like how we...
It's important.
It's really important to...
Okay.
This is the TV room.
Here.
What?
You found it??
It was here all along.
I'm happy.
Let's go!
Let's finish this!
No fucking way!
We can finish it!
I fucking believe that!
Oh my god!
It was in a fucking...
We were in this room before for so long!
It was in there.
Okay, body room.
Where's the body room?
There are all the red ones!
No, that's the red door.
That's the door.
Around here!
Yeah, is it here?
Around here.
No, that's the tutorial.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Let's go back to the red room again.
Oh, I got the hide here.
Here?
No, that's the tutorial.
You're in the tutorial.
Where was the body room again?
Where was the body room?
Where is it?
Did I pick it up?
I did.
I can't believe.
Oh my god.
I'm in the mirror room.
Where am I?
I'm so lost.
Not here.
Where are we?
This is the door room.
Not here.
We need to...
I'm not okay.
I'M NOT OKAY!
YOU SAID!
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Woah.
That's okay.
Everything is okay.
I still have my one Almond Water.
Okay.
We're fine.
You said we're fine.
We're okay.
There is the enemy.
I FOUND IT.
FOUND IT.
OH MY GOD.
Okay.
What was their name?
It was like Leia or some shit.
Leia.
Oh my god!
Mirror!
Mirror room
go!
I heard the sound!
What?
What are you seeing?
What happened?
Oh my god.
We did it!
We finished this puzzle!
We gotta go find...
We fucking did it!
Oh my god.
Mirror room!
I heard the... I'm so proud of ourself.
Let's go!
Let's go to the mirror room!
You saw him!
Let's go!
Follow me!
I'll be responsible for this.
Don't worry.
It's gonna be fine.
We did this.
Here.
We're so gonna find the mirror room.
There we go!
Here!
Come here!
You saw him!
The door is open!
Look!
This is new!
What the fuck?
I don't like anything new.
How do I... How do I use this?
Okay.
Interact.
How do I use it?
How do I use the screwdriver?
Screwdriver?
I don't have it.
No, I do.
But how do I use it?
Oh my god.
There's a... Is there a fuse?
No, I don't have fuse too.
Wait.
Blue?
Yellow?
No?
I can't open that.
What was the color?
What are those colors for?
I don't know.
We need fuses but I don't try to find where the fuses are.
Yeah.
I have nothing in my inventory right now.
It's pretty empty.
Okay.
I have everything.
Wait.
Maybe this?
Okay.
What's this?
What about this mirror?
There are multiple layers of stone too.
But only three can be up at the same time.
Oh!
Okay.
But what color?
What color do they have to be?
I have no idea.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Okay.
I get it.
It's not this one.
Alright.
Okay.
Go to the door.
And then I'm gonna...
I'm gonna talk to you.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna walkie-talkie.
Go to the door and tell me if it's green.
Go to the door.
And start.
Which door?
Okay.
Wait.
I'll go to the door.
I'm gonna go to the door.
And then you flip the switches.
And I'll tell you if it's green.
I'll tell you if it's yes or no.
Okay.
Okay?
So which...
Come here.
So...
You start.
Okay.
So you see this door?
So I...
One of the switches I did was correct.
So I want you to keep doing...
You can only have three switches at the same time.
So you turn...
You turn on the switch.
Each switch.
And I'll tell you if it's yes or no.
If it's no, turn it off.
Okay.
If it's yes, keep it on.
Okay?
Alright.
Use the walkie-talkie.
Okay.
Alright.
Go.
So...
I'm just gonna...
Up the leveler, right?
Yeah.
In the rack.
No.
How about this?
Turn it off.
Okay.
I just...
Yeah.
How about this?
No.
Turn it off.
Wait.
Yes.
Oh no.
Yeah.
Wait.
Don't...
Turn it back on.
Yeah.
We need one more.
It's not working.
Oh.
You have to turn...
Go up.
It's not working.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
I know which one.
I think.
Wait.
Like this one's not working.
Let me... Let me try.
Let me try.
I think it was this one.
Is this yes or no?
Oh.
This was yes.
Okay.
We need to turn off one more.
Turn off.
We need to turn on.
Sorry.
Okay.
So this one?
We ignore that.
Okay.
It goes on again.
Why is this so hard?
Okay.
Why is it still...?
Why is it still on?
Let me pass.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh okay, I did it.
It worked!
Awesome.
Sorry.
That was hard.
We did it!
Yay!
Wait, there's a radiation suit!
We did it!
I
need to go!
Oh my god.
We did it!
Put it on!
Calm down, I need to heal myself like real quick.
I don't remember what these do.
Okay.
Okay, awesome.
Put it on.
Oh yeah, we did it!
Put it on!
Put it in your inventory!
Okay, let's go to the radiation room.
Open your inventory and put it on!
Oh okay, I thought I put it on already.
Equip!
How about this?
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah.
We did it!
Guys!
I need to know...
How much more do we have of this?
This stuff at this level.
I have no idea.
We're gonna figure it out after the radiation room.
You don't have it on yet!
You don't have your radiation suit on.
Well I thought I had my suit on.
Wait, do I have my suit on?
You are.
Yeah, wait wait wait.
Yeah, you don't.
I equipped it already.
Wait, use, use.
Yeah, there we go!
Whoa!
Okay.
Looking pretty handsome in that suit.
We have two more puzzles!
You saw it!
Among us!
Okay, base room!
Radiation room!
We need to find the radiation room!
For god, where was that?
I don't remember where was that!
It's not this way!
Okay, now, now figure it out.
Okay, follow me.
Two more puzzles!
Follow my six sense.
Okay?
Alright, here we go.
Here.
Oh, that's the red room.
No.
That's the red room.
Oh my god.
That is... Yeah, yeah, yeah, here!
We can go!
Nice!
Awesome!
Here, here!
We can do it!
No, no.
All the way.
All the way there.
Oh yeah, yeah?
No, no.
This is base room.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Radiation room is here.
But there's a... It's right here.
No, no, no, no, no.
But there's a red light.
Whoa, okay.
I guess we just go through.
Okay.
I found it!
Here.
Yeah!
Let's go.
Alright, I need to read this again.
Okay.
Oh, there is a locker that only will open the radiation room is on low level.
To achieve this, the class is required only to be able to increase...
What is this?
Gas mask.
Some items on the rooms are contaminated.
Oh, okay.
So what we need to do is find the items with the most contamination.
Okay.
With the most radiation.
Oh, so I need to use the radiation...
Okay.
This has...
This is four.
Four?
Alright.
So, wait.
What is this?
One...
Is the... Okay.
This one has a lot of radiation.
Okay.
Hold the radiation one.
I'm just gonna hold it on flashlight.
I found one has a lot of radiation.
And then we spray it.
Okay.
Got it.
There you go.
Yeah.
Okay.
That gas mask has a lot of radiation.
Whoa.
There's a monster here.
I hear the footsteps.
Yeah.
Me too.
I do too.
I don't like that.
I don't like that too.
Okay.
That's the door.
Woo!
Okay.
Does this have radiation?
No.
Okay.
No?
Alright.
Uh...
Hmm.
Wait.
What was this?
Teddy bear.
Radiation?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Spray it.
Spray it with your extinguisher.
Okay.
Hold on a moment.
Yeah.
Use...
And then...
Did you spray it?
Yeah.
I did that.
He's spraying.
Okay.
Nice.
This one too.
Okay.
Spray it.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh my god.
This game has like a lot of things to do.
What about this?
This one.
Yeah.
Alright.
I don't know.
I think that's...
Alright.
I'm gonna check.
Let's...
I'm gonna check the door.
Oh, we should have sprayed the door.
We should have...
Okay.
This one.
Choose.
Okay.
This.
I'm trying to figure out this... the wheelchair.
Okay.
Nice.
This one too.
The horsey.
Awesome.
Are we spraying just every item?
We have to go back.
We have to find the door.
Where's the door?
I see the yellow door.
Oh, here.
Here.
Before.
We... Spray the door.
Wait.
What?
No!
We needed one, two more items!
What?
You said we gotta spray the door.
I thought we... I thought we did it!
I thought we did it!
What did... What did I do wrong?
Did I do something wrong?
No, we need... We didn't find enough items.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
I dropped it.
No!
We need to find two more items that's contaminated!
I thought we found it all!
Two more.
Yeah, we need to find two more.
Nooo,
I didn't find all of them!
How about this?
No.
Here?
Looking?
This one?
How about here?
How about this area?
No, there's none.
There's none here.
I'm looking.
What the fuck?
Is it here?
Can I just spray every item we see?
No.
I mean, technically, yeah.
Right?
Technically, we can.
But I feel like that's gonna make it harder for us.
Yeah.
Where the fuck?
Where were the last two items?
I can't figure it out.
No, the three we couldn't... I don't know where the last two items are.
I can't find it.
Where's the last two items?
That's radioactive!
Oh no, that's the door.
No, that's the locker.
This one?
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna use the spray can.
Oh yeah, true.
Yeah.
Okay, we gotta mark the door.
We're gonna mark the door?
We have to find... Okay, find the ra... Oh shit!
Oh god, that scared me.
That's a smiley face in there.
Don't look.
Oh no.
Cup in corner next to the chair?
There's a cup in the corner?
What?
Yes.
Oh my god.
What is it?
I heard the doggo.
No, not the doggo.
Leave us alone.
Okay, wait, wait.
Let's mark the items first.
Yeah.
Okay, this one is... Mark this item was radioactive.
Can you mark it?
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
With a spray can.
I have no spray can.
Oh shit.
Wait, what?
Okay.
I have no spray can.
Okay, here.
I'm gonna drop my spray can.
Here you go.
Um...
Okay.
Cup is in the similar...
Well, I can pick it up.
Why?
What happened to your spray can?
I can pick it up for the moment.
Okay.
Well, I can pick it up.
Oh, I think I got too much item.
Got it.
So, I'm gonna drop one of the... Invalid Peel.
And... I believe I can grab the spray can right now.
Nice.
Oh, it's the horse?
The horse?
Wait, wait.
Come with me.
I remember where the horse is.
Oh, the horse toy.
Yeah.
Okay.
I didn't know... I don't know where the horse is.
I forgot.
Yeah.
Where's the horse?
Is it here?
Yeah.
I found it.
Here.
Okay.
And where's the cup?
Cup?
Okay.
There's a cup somewhere.
Is it this?
No, that's Moth Jelly.
Not here.
I'm just gonna go find a cup.
That's Moth Jelly.
What do you mean?
Cup, cup, cup, cup, cup, cup, cup.
Papers?
Here.
Is it?
Spray the paper.
How about this one?
How about this paper?
Spray... No!
Spray the paper.
Spray it.
Doki, doki.
Doki...
Just spray it!
Th... This one?
Spray everything!
Didn't work.
I don't know!
I'm spraying everything I see!
No!
The time limit!
Just spray every item!
It doesn't matter anymore!
Just spray every item you see!
We split up!
We split up and start spraying!
I'll just spray everything I see.
We split up!
I can't!
It doesn't matter!
We have to spray everything!
Eventually it'll work!
I've given up.
Just spray everything!
Spray and pray!
Okay.
Alright.
We must be close.
So anyway, I just started blasting.
Did you spray everything?
I just spray everything I see as possible.
Oh boy!
There's still six items?
It's still working!
There's still six items!
It's not even working!
Keep spraying!
I just keep spraying!
Eventually it'll work!
I'm not gonna play.
Why?
Did it open?
Did you hear that?
I sprayed it alive!
I heard the door was open.
No, it's four.
It's four.
Keep spraying!
Oh my god.
Four items.
Okay.
I just keep spraying.
We have nothing else to spray anymore.
There has to be more.
Oh, wait.
This one?
Is it?
There's always more!
There has to be more items!
I can't find it!
Wait, wait, wait.
You said I can't walk through!
You said...
I have no idea!
Wait, hold on.
You said you're blocking the door!
I can't spray!
What about this?
Spray the walls!
Just spray ourselves.
What about this?
The paper must be radiated too.
I sprayed everything, I swear to god.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm just gonna...
Three items!
Three items?!
Three more!
Okay.
Two now, right?
Oh, let's see, let's see.
Okay.
There's still three more, three more.
Spray everything.
Do the lockers get radiated?!
Oh my god.
Spray everything.
Yeah.
I bet.
Okay.
Three more, still three more.
What about now?
Two, two more!
Two more!
Where is the last two?!
I swear to god.
I just can't!
I swear to fucking god.
Two more!
I found one!
I did it!
Sprint everything!
Let's go!
Why is this so hard?
We did it!
Alright, there's a creature that wanders aimlessly on some backroom zones.
It seems to have no conscience but until it's hungry.
At which point it becomes aggressive.
Beings look for the closest subject to eat.
It distinguishes from other creatures.
It looks to skin its victims.
Oh, okay.
And steal their skin.
It's reasoning that it can even spell blood over long distance.
Oh shit, okay.
Did you get it?
Yeah, I did.
But like...
How do we open?
Alright, I did it.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my god, there is the progress.
We're doing... I think we're doing fine.
Oh my god, we're doing so well.
Yeah, we're going well.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm a little worried though.
Wait, are we gonna die if we go down?
I don't know.
No, don't do that.
Don't do that.
Wait.
It's locked.
How do we... Wait.
Wait.
Where do we go?
Where are we going?
Well, I guess we go down.
Okay, let's go.
Did they die?
Now what?
We did it!
We beat the level!
Now what?
We did it!
You saw me!
Now what?
Yeah!
And this is where we call it.
Okay.
Now what?
This is where we end the game.
The game?
Okay, how about...
You know what?
I think it's fine.
I think we did really well.
I think, you know...
I think so.
Yeah, you know...
We spent two hours upstream.
And there are a lot of progress.
Yeah, we made so much progress.
You know...
I think so.
We did.
Yeah.
We did a lot.
I don't think we don't have to do everything if we, you know, enjoy the game.
You know what?
Yeah.
I'm proud of myself.
You know, I'm proud of ourselves too.
We did so well.
We might have got stuck a lot.
But...
You know what?
Yeah.
We did so well on easy.
We did so...
Even though it was easy mode, we were pretty good at this game, right?
I don't believe that it was easy mode.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, guys, I was joking.
When I said it was easy, I meant hard.
We were definitely on hard mode, guys.
Yeah.
It was definitely...
Yeah, you suck.
Don't believe that.
That was a hard mode, okay, chat?
Yeah.
Thank you for coming to this.
Thank you for playing with me, you son.
Thank you too.
That was so much fun.
It was really fun.
And chat, thank you very much for being really patient at our game talk.
Thank you so much for backseating us, but kindly, you know?
I will give a credit for you guys for your patience.
There's no fan base being this much patient.
Dragoon, Yurei, you guys are the best.
And you know what?
Have an awesome day.
Yeah, thank you guys.
Thank you for coming, you son.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Thank you, everybody.
I'm going to talk to my chat real quick, you son.
But thank you again.
I really had a great time.
By the way, chat, there's going to be my 3D concert.
Yeah, yeah, check out Yusuke's 3D concert.
I am definitely not here for self-promote.
Because that's too much sacrifice to myself.
Just for fucking promotion, I sacrificed too much for myself.
I killed so much brain cells for this.
But you know what?
I think it was kind of worth it.
You know?
Okay, I'll talk to you later.
Okay, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Oh my god, I just insta-quit.
I just insta-quit the game.
Shit, that was so fun.
Oh my god.
I can't believe we beat the tutorial.
I'm so proud of us.
We did it.
We beat the tutorial.
Oh my god, I can't believe.
I can't believe we did the
tutorial.
I swear to fucking god.
I'm going to...
Oh, where am I?
Whoa, okay.
Oh my god.
Thank you again to Yusuke for joining me today.
That was really fun.
I'm going to go read some books.
Oh my god, I haven't read Super Chats in so long.
Give me a sec.
Donation reading time.
Oh my gosh, it's been a while since we did donation reading.
So, I'm gonna read some Super Chats.
I'm sorry if I can't get to a lot of the Super Chats today.
I'm a bit tired.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun though.
That was a little bit of a mess.
But we did it.
We did it everybody!
We fucking beat the tutorial!
I'm so proud of all of us.
I really am.
It truly was one of the hardest games I've ever played.
I can't believe how much we fucking struggled.
Oh my god, man.
Thank you for all the gifted memberships too!
Thank you everybody.
Thank you guys.
Alright, um... let's see.
NS5, how's the backlog of Super Chats?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's like pretty rough.
It's a pretty rough backlog.
I really appreciate all the support.
I really do appreciate it.
It's a lot.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
MechanicalLandShark, itoki, what is your favorite design of Shockwave?
G1, Prime, Cylinder, OA, or God forbid live action?
I think like... OG.
The OG one with the mask is my favorite.
Oh wait, sorry, that's Soundwave.
I don't know why I thought I said Soundwave.
I thought you said Soundwave, not Shockwave.
Shockwave, I don't really care much about Shockwave's design.
Because like Shockwave wasn't really my favorite Transformer.
I liked Soundwave more than Shockwave.
Because like Soundwave was like a fucking DJ.
So like, for me...
Shockwave, I don't really care too much about their design.
But if I had to pick, I think it'd be like... Prime, I think.
I think Shockwave Prime was a nice design.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
ColdDeath, itoki, you're really amazing.
We all support you.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Let's see...
Phoenix, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Voitan, it was fun to see you, son.
You look for the exit in your room.
You're average office building.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We got super fucking lost.
I swear to God.
We kept trying to find the fucking...
The amount of times we got...
We were just stuck in the tutorial...
The elevator beginning.
I swear to God.
We were always stuck.
We always came back to the elevator.
No matter what.
Yes, son.
Thank you for the Akka soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks, Dragoons.
Thanks, Doki.
Thank you for the Akka.
Yes.
Make sure to check out Yu-san.
And also their covers.
And their music.
And their original songs.
And also check out their first 3D concert that's coming up.
I don't remember when.
But like, it's coming up.
Simu, can't wait for part 2 of the tutorial.
I can't believe that was the tutorial.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mister, remember Doki.
The tutorial was all the friends we made along the way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Pixel, love your stream.
Any chance for Dynasty Warriors 3 someday?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, I can actually play like the good Dynasty Warriors.
Oh my God.
We can play the good ones.
Maybe in the future.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see.
Where was I in the super chat?
Doki, I think this is dead.
The dog.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mister 2, we beat the tutorial.
Let's go!
I hope to see Yuusan again.
It was fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope so too.
I hope we do more collabs in the future with Yuusan.
Anyway, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Watching all play was a rollercoaster.
But it was also so much fun.
Keep being awesome, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you guys enjoyed that collab.
It's nice to be able to collab with them.
And I can't wait to do lots of collabs with lots of different people in the future.
Saber!
Vocal exercise.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I like how the only time I died was when I just gave up.
I was just like...
Fuck this.
I don't even know where the fucking eye is!
Just let this end me.
Anyway, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Watching all play was a rollercoaster.
But it was also so much fun.
Wait, did I just read that?
I'm so sorry.
If I did, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your first super chat, Adrien.
Thank you!
The two of you make up one brain cell in that tutorial.
Peak content.
Keep it up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
PoonV!
Thank you for the machenta!
Thank you!
Liquid, thank you for the super chat!
Just got home from driving in the snow storm and had your stream playing in the background.
I was focused on the road, of course.
Thank you for keeping me company!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm glad that I kept you company.
I'm glad you guys...
I'm glad you guys have all enjoyed today's stream.
That was really, really fun.
Before the stream, I was super tired too.
I feel like every time I'm not streaming, I'm just very tired.
I was so tired physically and mentally.
And so I was just like, Oh man, I hope I'll be able to stream.
I feel so tired.
But every time I turn on the stream, I just go like 100%.
I was just like, alright, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I'm a content creator.
I got this!
I can do this!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome to the Ambership.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Sometimes when you're lost, it's great to go back at the start to figure out your way.
You saw while being lost going back to the tutorial door.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe.
Okay, Nem, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe the eye was in the locker the entire time.
I can't believe it.
The one...
The room we hid in for so long.
We kept hiding in the room.
We kept hiding in.
And it was in there the entire time.
I can't believe it.
None of us looked at it.
We all did not think it was there.
I kept in that room so fucking long.
And I didn't even realize it was there.
Andrew, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Horror games are scary, but your uratics and nissan's hyperventilation.
I honestly could not take your fear seriously.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
I'm going to call it here now.
And...
And rest up.
But thank you everybody for all the super chats.
I'm really sorry if I couldn't read yours in time.
But thank you everybody.
I really had an amazing time.
Hanging out with everybody.
And playing this game with you, son.
I hope you guys had an amazing time with us.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
If you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.